good evening tonight we are learning
more now about the pilot of the plane
that crashed thursday morning in the
south part of the valley
thanks for joining us here at five i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis that
crash happened just after 9 30 in the
area of the valley view in pebble the
pilot took off from north las vegas
airport
headed to san diego california but tried
to make an emergency landing
at the henderson airport and we were
covering the crash
as it happened at raven and henson
tonight we're getting a little bit of a
closer look at the crash site
we have new video captured on a home
security camera essentially showing the
plane descending
taking a nosedive and then crashing now
right now the national transportation
safety board
is leading the investigation a news now
reached out to the agency it says the
primary focus right now
is collecting information and
documenting the aircraft
while no official identification has
been confirmed
friends of the pilot are identifying him
as robert golow
he is the owner of air charter express
the business's website promotes air
transportation from
san diego los angeles and las vegas
robert rc was a friend of golos for
nearly three decades
and told our sister stationed in san
diego california
he just saw him last week rc remembers
golo
as a cautious pilot who just loved to
fly
i actually got to fly with him and then
a few days later he
was gone very cautious very
conscientious
careful and safe
so my first thought is
this must have been a really nasty
mechanical
problem says it won't determine the
cause of that crash
this early in this investigation has
only been less a little bit more than 24
hours
the agency says it typically takes 12 to
24 months
before a final report is issued a
preliminary report will be available
we're told somewhere between
10 and 12 days now the passenger in that
plane crash has not yet been identified
and of course we'll bring you updates as
soon as we learn more details we'll keep
an eye on the story for you
brian